i haven't done a video on mask of the
phantasm yet and last night i was laying
in bed
i saw a vision of the phantasm
and the phantasm said your angel of
death awaits
and i knew i had to do a video on this
movie that's not at all how it happened
but i'm really glad
i was like it dawned on me i was like
i've never done a video
on mask of the phantasm this needs to
change
so let's do that
batman mask of the phantasm so batman
mask of the phantasm came out i believe
in 1993
around there anyway look i saw the
trailer on the vhs a free willy so it
was around there and it was a
theatrically released
movie which is funny because it's it's
this
underrated batman movie that underrated
in this sense of
it's overlooked a lot of times when
people think about the batman movies
like when they think about batman movies
is like burton schumacher and nolan but
in between
burton and schumacher is this little gem
called batman mask of the phantasm so i
suppose it's underrated in that sense
but most
batman fans are always like yeah mask of
the phantasm one of the best batman
movies out there and it is quite a
hidden gem so the plot is it is in the
vein of batman the animated series and
there's this new player in gotham
the phantasm who's never actually called
the phantasm in the movie
but i digress for the sake of us we call
the phantasm the phantasm looks like a
phantasm so why not and the phantasm
is offing gangsters in gotham i want you
and i remember thinking like oh phantasm
this new batman villain and even when i
walked out of the movie i was young and
i was like oh batman mask of the
phantasm of phantasm was the new villain
and although phantasm is a great iconic
new
character i mean instant classic
character
among batman i'm baffled that phantasm's
not used more but phantasm's not a
villain
it's not like phantasm's going around
and messing with
innocent people phantasm's like batman
only if batman was like
let's just kill him get it over with and
once i realized that after the first
time i saw mask of the phantasm
it just made the plot better it just
made mask of the phantasm
more complex take a shot every time i
say phantasm
are you dead yet i'm sorry i love how
bruce wayne's a really conflicted guy in
that there's this scene
this is actually the most conflicted
i've ever seen bruce wayne
in any of the movies like he's always
had that
you know like i could give up the cape
and cow if it means rachel doss he'll be
with me
did you mean it you know he's always
been like i'll drop the cape and cow
if you'll be with me rachel dawes no oh
she got blown up i guess i'll take
catwoman so bruce wayne's struggling
with batman you know we've seen that yes
but is any of it
executed as well is that scene in mask
of the phantasm where bruce wayne is
just crying at his parents grave asking
them for permission
to go back on this promise that he made
them he's like i didn't expect to be
happy
but i'm happy isn't that okay it's nuts
it reminds me
there was this philosopher on an
airplane and he
kind of assessed a passenger was on the
plane with him
and he said moments of levity actually
caused him pain
that is what i thought of when i saw
this scene before doing this video it's
it's good [ __ ] and masking the phantasm
actually does a really good job at
balancing all the cogs in this machine
in this hour and 15 minute long movie
explaining it i would you would swear
they needed more time to fit it all in
but they somehow fit it seeing bruce
wayne become batman this backstory love
story in which he's conflicted with
being batman and he wants to be with
this person you know he can't have both
this phantasm who's offing mobsters
people think it's batman
then amongst all of it thrown into the
mix is the joker which they could have
just thrown in because it's the joker
and it's a batman animated movie and you
kind of need the joker because it's the
joker dude is the star
of the highest grossing rated r film of
all time granted master the phantasm was
decades before that but it just goes to
show having joker on screen
is usually not a bad thing but he's not
just thrown in here for the sake of
having the joker in an animated movie
he's actually a very important cog in
this machine
and he brings the kind of chaos and
unpredictable nature you want the joker
to bring into a movie like this just
when you think you've figured out the
structure of mask of the phantasm the
joker comes in
voiced by the legendary mark hamill to
shake it the [ __ ] up
and there's actually a pretty epic
reveal in this movie coupled with the
joker's laugh that just
chilled me to the bone when i was a kid
actually still gives me chills now when
i'm talking about it it's so good
and this plot is complex this is
definitely the most complex batman movie
up until it came out definitely up until
nolan took over and even then
there's a lot of things that the dark
knight gets all the shine for
that mask of the phantasm actually did
first like batman begins we see batman's
origin
mask of the phantasm was actually the
first time on the big screen we saw
batman origin story we saw bruce wayne
become batman in these flashbacks we
actually see where he gets the
inspiration for the batmobile and you
see he's frustrated like they weren't
afraid of me they need to be afraid of
me and you see how he becomes batman and
why
he becomes batman you know the dark
knight gets all the shine for being the
batman mob drama
mask of the phantasm was that first you
could say that the dark knight goes
deeper into it and
you know it does because of the time
allowed i suppose that
is a thing to address as much as they
use the time they have to its fullest is
still an hour and 15 minutes and they
have a lot of plot in there and it all
works but there are a couple moments
where it's like oh
intrigue okay you just gave me the
answer about the phantasm thing okay if
this movie was a full two hour long
movie or as long as the dark knight i
can only imagine what they could have
done with it but for the time they had
they
totally used it well i will say one of
my gripes is
sometimes the visuals i mean the
animation
is more refined than batman the animated
series not that batman the animated
series is bad
it's one of the it's the greatest
animated series of all time
in my opinion but i bought the series of
batman the animated series on blu-ray
and it had mask of the phantasm the
blu-ray in there and sometimes it's
crystal clear and sometimes it's just
fuzzier and you're like oh that's
weirdly fuzzy in the next scene it's
clear
you're like i don't know why one of the
gripes i've heard i haven't heard it a
lot but i have
heard it in whispers and comments out
there is the fact that
this feels like basically a longer
episode of batman the animated series
but i don't think that
is showing a lack of quality with mask
of the phantasm i think that just shows
the quality of batman the animated
series and this movie is just an
epic one it has heart it has emotion it
has the feels it has
depth in a way that you want to see from
a batman movie it's a compelling bruce
wayne drama as well as an epic batman
story and it's phantasm's tragedy
phantasm is a tragic character but it
never
ceases to be batman's movie mask of the
phantasm just
has enough room for everyone to thrive
and
shine on in an hour and 15 minutes
that's got to be the best time
management i've ever seen in a movie
batman mask of the phantasm has aged
like a fine wine
and it is awesome tacular
[Music]
your angel of death awaits such an
epic phrase all right so batman mask of
the phantasm have you seen it what did
you think about it it's on netflix right
now so
check it out if you haven't seen it in
years it's been a few years since i've
seen it
and i just got more out of it this time
surprisingly so but whatever you think
of it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you